This is going to be a real quick episode because Arnett's got to pee. I got to take a leak. So bad. So we're going to do the episode and then you're going to pee, Will, or do you want to pee? You're going to pee and then we're going to do the episode. You want to pee now? Wait.
这一集会非常快，因为Arnett得去尿尿。我得去撒泡尿。太急了。所以我们要先录这一集，然后你去尿尿，Will，还是你想先去？你要去尿尿，然后我们再录这一集。你现在想去尿尿吗？等等。
I tell you what. I tell you what. I'm going to run out during the music. Yeah. And then during the music, I'll be peeing right now. It's an all new smartphone. Okay, I got something. I got something.
我跟你说。我跟你说。我打算在放音乐的时候跑出去。对。然后在放音乐的时候，我就去尿尿。这是一个全新的智能手机。好吧，我有东西要说。我有东西要说。
Ready? Here we go. Sean's got something. Hang on. Why does it look like you're reading off a cue card? Are you reading off cue cards today? What are you talking about? Do you have to, if you flip your camera around, could you imagine Scotty's just there dropping
准备好了吗？开始了。Sean有东西要说。等等。为什么看起来你在读提示卡？你今天在读提示卡吗？你在说什么？如果你把摄像机转过来，你能想象Scotty就在那里扔
them? Just like Wally, who we haven't mentioned in a while, Wally over at SNL, the greatest cue card guy of all time. Who is the brother of Spike Ferrison? Wait, what? Yeah. Yeah. I didn't know that.
那些卡片吗？就像Wally一样，我们有一阵子没提他了，SNL的Wally，史上最伟大的提示卡小哥。他是Spike Ferrison的兄弟？等等，什么？是啊。是啊。我不知道。
We've talked about Wally before. He's the one of the all time. Wally. And super nice. Wally. Wally. Yeah, I got something about, you know, for Christmas a month or two ago, whenever Christmas was.
我们之前聊过Wally。他是史上最棒的之一。Wally。人超级好。Wally。Wally。是啊，我有件事，你知道，一两个月前过圣诞节的时候，不管圣诞节是什么时候。
Sure. Scotty got me this. It's called Wubbles. The Wubbles Learn to Crochet Kit. Yeah. Huh. That qualifies as a present in your house, huh? Yeah.
当然。Scotty给我买了这东西。叫Wubbles。Wubbles钩针编织入门套件。是啊。呵。这在你家也算礼物啊？是啊。
And it's everything's in this box. And you know what? He got you that instead because he got sick of saying, shut up. Shut up. So he just thought, fuck, he'll be distracted. He just, and then I don't have to spend my day going, shut up. Shut the fuck up. Now you're busy being quiet and knitting, and he's got a couple of weapons around now.
盒子里什么都有。你知道吗？他给你买那个是因为他厌倦了说“闭嘴”。闭嘴。所以他想，去他的，让他分心吧。他只是，然后我就不用整天说，闭嘴。闭上你的臭嘴。现在你忙着安静地织东西，而且他现在身边有几个武器。
They come with the kit just in case you start to run your mouth again. Right. But isn't that good? Wait, Jay, didn't you say you used to crochet or something? No, my sister did. My sister used to have a knitting, a true. No, I said, no, my great-grandmother did. Back on the homestead, my great-grandmother did when they were just, you know, you know,
套件里自带的，以防你又开始胡说八道。对。但这难道不好吗？等等，Jay，你不是说你以前钩过针还是什么的吗？不，我姐姐钩过。我姐姐以前有个编织，真的。不，我说的是，不，我曾祖母钩过。在老家的时候，我曾祖母在他们只是，你知道，你知道，
trying to wait the winter out that she did. That's what I think I always mean. Now that little starter kit is unopened. It's been a few months since Christmas. I know. That's rude. I know. Do you know my mom, my mom knits a lot and she knits the kid's sweater.
试图熬过冬天的时候她做过。我一直想表达的就是这个。现在那个入门套件还没拆封。离圣诞节已经过去几个月了。我知道。真没礼貌。我知道。你知道我妈吗，我妈很会织毛衣，她给孩子们织毛衣。
This is true story. And she knits the kid's sweater. It's for Christmas and stuff. She just sent some new one. Why wouldn't it be true? No, I know. And she would love to knit you boys a sweater. So would you both like a cardigan or a v-neck or a crew neck?
这是真实故事。她给孩子们织毛衣。为了圣诞节什么的。她刚寄来一件新的。为什么这不可能是真的？不，我知道。她很乐意给你们俩织件毛衣。所以你们俩想要开衫、V领还是圆领的？
I'd like a v-neck, please. I like it. Ask Alex. Ask Alex nicely and she'll do it. Alex, can you please make me a v-neck, something that I can wear when I play golf with your son? I'll make it a turtleneck because I can't pull those off and I know very few people that can't.
我想要V领的，谢谢。我喜欢。问Alex。礼貌地问Alex，她会做的。Alex，你能帮我织件V领的吗，就是那种我跟你儿子打高尔夫时能穿的？我会织成高领的，因为我穿不了那种，而且我知道很少有人能驾驭。
Thick or do you want it kind of thick or kind of thin? Thin, you know. Kind of thin. Okay, Shawnee. I would like a crew neck for me, but for Jason, can the V go all the way down to show some of his cleavage? Super low. You'd like to see?
厚一点，还是你想要那种厚一点的或者薄一点的？薄一点的，你知道。薄一点的。好的，Shawnee。我想要一件圆领的，但对于Jason，那个V领能不能开得很低，露出他的乳沟？超级低。你想看？
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Well below both. But you want a crew neck, Shawnee? I want a crew neck, Alex, please. Yes. And maybe Alex, maybe put in some sort of a catch pouch like a kangaroo catch pouch for Shawn just for the pros. And do you guys want like some Canadian, you want a little Canadian flag on it or maple
是啊，是啊，是啊。远低于两者。但你想要圆领的，Shawnee？我想要圆领的，Alex，拜托了。好的。而且Alex，也许可以给Shawn加个那种袋鼠兜，专门放高尔夫球用的。你们想要那种加拿大的，想要个小加拿大国旗或者枫叶什么的吗？
leaves or anything? No, thank you. I would do that. Don't say so quick. But an American flag. Okay, jeez. I'll do like a nice little tiny maple flag. That'd be cool.
不，谢谢。我会那样做的。别拒绝得那么快。但要美国国旗。好吧，天哪。我会织个漂亮的小枫叶旗。那会很酷。
Like in a corner of the back or something. You know what? The Canadian actually, if you think about it, this is a good tie-in to our next guest. You like segues. You like segues? I think you just did the segues right there. Let's get right into it. I am.
比如在背后的角落里什么的。你知道吗？其实加拿大这个，如果你仔细想想，这和我们下一位嘉宾衔接得很好。你喜欢转场。你喜欢转场吗？我觉得你刚才就做了个转场。我们直接开始吧。我是。
We're into a segues. Oh yeah. And he's somebody who's been making me laugh and also making me feel like, wow, this is so great that somebody Canadian who's from where I'm from can do this at such a high level. So it's inspirational. This is going to be a funny style. And we've only sort of passed, really sort of said hello kind of once and of course
我们进入转场了。哦耶。他是一个一直让我发笑，同时也让我觉得，哇，能有像我老乡那样的加拿大人在这么高的水平上做到这一点，真是太棒了。所以这很鼓舞人心。这会是一种有趣的风格。我们只是稍微打过照面，真的只是打过一次招呼，当然
he was just as gracious and had good vibe and kind of spirit that you could feel as I thought he would be in addition to being super, super hilarious. And once I start listing his credits, you're going to know who it is. But suffice to say that he created a show that won nine Emmys one year, which is the biggest ever for comedy in one year, including picking up two of his own. He comes from his background in comedy is like of the highest order from just, you know, his credits are or are comedies that are that are just enshrined in the Mount Rushmore of comedy, whether it be sketch or film.
他就像我想象中那样亲切，有着那种你能感受到的良好氛围和精神，而且超级超级搞笑。一旦我开始列举他的作品，你就会知道他是谁了。但足以说明，他创作的一部剧一年赢得了九项艾美奖，这是喜剧史上一年内获奖最多的，包括他自己拿下的两项。他的喜剧背景是最高级别的，你知道，他的作品都是喜剧界的拉什莫尔山，无论是小品还是电影。
And then he went on to TV to create this series that he created with his son. Oh, they did this series for about seven great seasons. Well, let's get it. Stop making him wait. Great Eugene Levy. Good Lord Eugene. He is. There he is.
然后他去电视界创作了这个系列，是他和他儿子一起创作的。哦，他们做了这个系列，一共七个伟大的季度。好吧，我们开始吧。别让他等了。伟大的Eugene Levy。天哪，Eugene。他来了。就是他。
Gentlemen. Yeah. How are you? How are you? Better now. Better now. I know. I feel like jumping out of a cake, but there's no cake.
先生们。是啊。你好吗？你好吗？现在好多了。现在好多了。我知道。我感觉像从蛋糕里跳出来一样，但这里没有蛋糕。
Eugene, I'm going to, I'm going to see you for dinner tomorrow. What? Yes. Fantastic. Boy, if I, I've never seen a look of shock before there was shock and I've never seen a look of like, how can I get out of this on someone's face? Sean, where's this dinner that he doesn't know about? It's at Marty's.
Eugene，我，我明天要和你一起吃晚饭。什么？是的。太棒了。天哪，如果我，我从来没见过这么震惊的表情，那是震惊，而且我从来没见过谁脸上露出那种“我怎么才能摆脱这个”的表情。Sean，他不知道的这顿饭在哪吃？在Marty家。
Where are you valaying tomorrow? Oh, at Marty's. Oh. Yeah. Eugene, I got to tell you, man, you know, as a Canadian, as a fellow Canadian, I'm just, first of all, I love that we're having yet another person who is part of the, the incredible production of Godspell in Toronto from 1971 or whatever it was. Thank you.
你明天在哪代客泊车？哦，在Marty家。哦。是啊。Eugene，我得告诉你，伙计，你知道，作为一个加拿大人，作为同胞，我首先，我很高兴我们又请到了一位参与了1971年多伦多《Godspell》那部不可思议的作品的人。谢谢。
Thank you. Please. The greatest, the greatest cast that opened at the, open at the Royal Alexander and moved up to the, I think the, the Bayview Playhouse, Bayview Playhouse. With the greatest cast of all time. Wait, is Bayview kind of small or I don't know that? Well, it's kind of about Lisa. It was, it was a smaller theatre in a section of the city that, that was not what you would
谢谢。拜托。那部在皇家亚历山大剧院首演，然后搬到，我想是，Bayview剧场，Bayview剧场。史上最伟大的演员阵容。等等，Bayview是不是有点小，我不了解？嗯，它有点像Lisa。它是一个较小的剧院，位于城市的一个区域，那不是你所说的
call the theatre district. No. No. I'm not entirely sure what, what the district was, but, but it was a theatre that we got to move into because they, they kicked us out. They only had us in the Royal Alex for three months. It was only booked over the summer, right, when they're, when, when everything is kind of low-key there.
剧院区。不。不。我不完全确定那是什么区，但，但那是一个我们得以搬进去的剧院，因为他们，他们把我们赶出来了。他们只让我们在皇家亚历山大剧院待了三个月。它只预订了夏天，对吧，当一切在那里都比较低调的时候。
Right. Yeah. So we had to be out in September, so they found this other theatre and we were there for the, for another year, but it was. Incredible. And remind us, remind us Eugenia, who else was in the cast, remind us. Yes. Okay.
对。是啊。所以我们必须在九月搬走，所以他们找到了这个剧院，我们在那里又待了一年，但它。不可思议。提醒我们，提醒我们Eugene，还有谁在演员阵容里，提醒我们。好的。
Well, Victor Garber, of course, was our, was our Jesus and he, he, he only played in the show for a month because they hired him to do the movie. So as soon as we opened the show, he was only in it for a month and then he got to go to New York and, and then shoot the movie. Sure. Big hair. And so Andrea Martin, of course, was, was in that show, but Andrea didn't get hired initially. And there was another girl that got hired for that classic day by day song.
嗯，Victor Garber，当然，是我们的耶稣，他，他只演了一个月，因为他们雇他去拍电影了。所以我们刚开演，他只演了一个月，然后他就去纽约，然后拍电影了。当然。头发很长。所以Andrea Martin，当然，也在那部剧里，但Andrea最初没被雇佣。还有另一个女孩被雇来唱那首经典的《Day by Day》。
Day by day. Yeah. It's called her the day by day girl. But I'm sorry, Eugene, sorry, really quick. Really? Do we have to wrap up? No, no, no. I was just going to say, if, if Cher, if Cher sang day by day, it would be do-ba-do.
《Day by Day》。是啊。叫她“Day by Day女孩”。但我很抱歉，Eugene，抱歉，很快。真的吗？我们必须结束了吗？不，不，不。我只是想说，如果，如果Cher，如果Cher唱《Day by Day》，那会是“do-ba-do”。
Okay. Go ahead. He's got Tourette's when it comes to that. It's almost Tourette's. He's got to get it out. So anyway, this girl got pregnant and they, they had to let her go. And so there was an opening and I was friends with Andrea at the time. So I, I called her to say, you know, we have the directors having a party tomorrow night.
好的。继续。他一提到那个就有妥瑞氏症。几乎是妥瑞氏症。他必须把它说出来。所以总之，这个女孩怀孕了，他们，他们不得不让她走。所以有一个空缺，我当时和Andrea是朋友。所以，我打电话给她说，你知道，导演明晚有个派对。
Why don't you come to the party and just bring your A game? Okay. Because, you know, you, they're looking for a replacement and she did and she was hysterical that night. Of course. And the next day the director calls in New York and says, you know, we, I think I found the girl and, and, and there you go, Andrea got in Marty Short, my good friend from Hamilton, Ontario.
你为什么不来参加派对，拿出你的看家本领？好的。因为，你知道，他们正在找替补，她去了，那天晚上她简直太搞笑了。当然。第二天导演从纽约打来电话说，你知道，我们，我想我找到那个女孩了，然后，就这样，Andrea加入了，Marty Short，我来自安大略省汉密尔顿的好朋友。
We went to school together and I talked Marty into coming in and auditioning for the show because I had auditioned for it. He was still writing his final exams at McMaster University at the time. Still is, by the way. And I, he works a little slower, not true. So he was in it, um, um, um, um, Gilda Radner. God bless. All in the cast.
我们一起上学，我劝说Marty来参加试镜，因为我试镜过了。他当时还在麦克马斯特大学写期末考试。顺便说一句，现在还在写。而且，他工作稍微慢一点，不是真的。所以他在里面，嗯，嗯，嗯，嗯，Gilda Radner。上帝保佑。都在演员阵容里。
Dave Thomas. Uh, Dave Thomas was in it. He was in the, uh, uh, what Marty likes to call the bee cast. It was like when, when everybody left after a year, they brought in a new cast and Dave came in as the new cast. I see. I see. And not Dave Thomas from Wendy's just for a listener.
Dave Thomas。嗯，Dave Thomas在里面。他在，嗯，嗯，Marty喜欢称之为B组。就是当，当一年后大家都离开时，他们带来了一批新演员，Dave作为新演员加入了。我明白了。我明白了。不是Wendy's的那个Dave Thomas，只是为了听众说明一下。
Not, not that. Oh shoot. That was in my mouth. Dave Thomas from the great white, the great white north. It was, it was, it was great. It was a great, it really was a fun time. And the great thing is we're still friends. We're all friends.
不是，不是那个。哦，该死。那东西在我嘴里。来自《Great White North》的Dave Thomas。它，它，它很棒。那真是一段有趣的时光。最棒的是我们现在还是朋友。我们都是朋友。
We became friends back then and we're still friends. And was it because of that, that you, I'll start at second city, SCTV, or? Well, that's what my good expression is. How did SCTV, all those same people end up, or a lot of those people end up in SCTV? What was that migration? Well we were very fortunate in Toronto back then in 72 because these were kind of bigger American productions that were coming into town. And we happened to hook like with Godspell was coming in from New York.
我们那时成了朋友，现在还是朋友。是因为那个，你，我开始在Second City，SCTV，还是？嗯，那是我常用的表达。SCTV是怎么回事，所有那些人，或者很多人最终都去了SCTV？那次迁移是怎么回事？嗯，我们在72年的多伦多非常幸运，因为当时有一些比较大的美国制作进入了城里。我们碰巧联系上了，比如《Godspell》是从纽约来的。
So we, you know, we auditioned for it. We, Marty and I, you know, got in. There were like probably 500 people auditioning for the show and we, and both of us got in. And again, when Godspell ran its course, second city moved up from Chicago to open a Toronto branch. And so, you know, we all went out and auditioned for that. Eugene, with all of these, all of these folks being such elite comedic minds at that time from that region, I mean, I bet you've been asked this question a million times.
所以我们，你知道，试镜了。Marty和我，你知道，进去了。当时大概有500人在试镜那部剧，我们，我们两个都进去了。而且再次，当《Godspell》演完后，Second City从芝加哥搬来开设了多伦多分部。所以，你知道，我们都去试镜了。Eugene，所有这些家伙当时都是那个地区顶尖的喜剧天才，我的意思是，我敢打赌你已经被问过一百万次这个问题了。
So I apologize. What's in the water? Yeah. Can you attribute it to anything? Was there, was there a cent? A leader, a tonal, comedic tonal leader that kind of freed all you guys up to kind of do the same hilarious take on things? I think I might have been the leader.
所以我道歉。水里有什么？是啊。你能归因于什么吗？有没有，有没有一个中心？一个领袖，一个音调，一个喜剧音调的领袖，让你们所有人都能自由地对事物做出同样搞笑的解读？我想我可能是那个领袖。
Yeah. You look like the leader. No, I'm, that's not true. I, you know, the odd thing is I'm not, you know, I've never been the biggest, the biggest thing I've had to deal with in my life is being introduced as comedian Eugene Levy because I'm not, I'm actually not a, not a comedian as, as so far 20 minutes into this, you guys can attest, but, you know, I've, I've, I've always gotten my laughs through characters and everything else, but as a, as a, as a human being, I'm not, you know, I don't consider
是啊。你看起来像领袖。不，我，那不是真的。我，你知道，奇怪的是我不是，你知道，我一生中不得不面对的最大的一件事就是被介绍为“喜剧演员Eugene Levy”，因为我不是，我其实不是一个，不是一个喜剧演员，正如你们在20分钟后可以证明的那样，但是，你知道，我，我一直通过角色和其他一切来获得笑声，但作为一个，作为一个人类，我不是，你知道，我不认为
myself. I don't, I don't kind of look through that comic prism the way, look at life through that prism the way stand-ups do, you know, where everything has to be funny. So, but you love improv and bits and stuff like that, right? Yeah, you are all like that. No, no, it's all, sure, because you can still get to do it through character. Yeah. Yeah.
我自己。我不，我不像单口喜剧演员那样通过那个喜剧棱镜看生活，你知道，在那里一切都必须是好笑的。所以，但你喜欢即兴表演和段子之类的，对吧？是啊，你们都那样。不，不，都是，当然，因为你仍然可以通过角色来做到这一点。是啊。是啊。
The scariest thing for me ever performing was playing anybody close to myself and then I would just like really just climb up and say, why am I doing this? You know? Right. But, you know, give me a mustache and some, you know, slinky glasses and a hat, you know? Well, the slinky glasses, you just have to attach to the frames you have now. No, but I, I get that. I feel the same way when people sort of say, well, sometimes say comedian and I'm like,
对我来说，表演中最可怕的事情就是扮演任何接近我自己的人，然后我就会真的退缩，说，我为什么要这样做？你知道？对。但是，你知道，给我一撇小胡子和一些，你知道，滑稽的眼镜和一顶帽子，你知道？嗯，滑稽的眼镜，你只需要把它装在你现在的镜框上。不，但我，我明白。当人们有时说“喜剧演员”时，我也感觉一样，我就像，
well, I'm not a comedian. I'm not a stand-up. I didn't come up through that. I didn't even, I mean, at least you were in Second City, so you were doing sketch comedy and then you did SETV, which was, you know, film sketch comedy. I didn't even do any of that either. So I, but I get that when people kind of slap that on you and you're like, well, I don't really think of myself as a, as a joke teller, as a comedian.
嗯，我不是喜剧演员。我不是单口演员。我不是那样出道的。我甚至，我的意思是，至少你在Second City，所以你在做小品喜剧，然后你做了SCTV，那是，你知道，电影小品喜剧。我甚至连那些都没做过。所以，但我明白当人们给你贴上那个标签时，你会觉得，嗯，我真的不认为自己是一个，一个讲笑话的人，一个喜剧演员。
So, man, I got to say, Eugene, I've gone back and looked at so many and I've, you know, obviously grew up with SETV and again, as a Canadian and growing up in Toronto, I, I, you know, we were so proud that we had SETV came from Toronto and we were so, we looked up to you guys. So you guys are the, the people that I watched and, and was able to go like, these guys did it. You know, not if these guys can do it, we can do it, we looked up to you guys. Well, you know, when you're starting anything in Canada or Toronto, the way we did, you,
所以，伙计，我得说，Eugene，我回去看了很多，而且我，你知道，显然是看着SCTV长大的，而且再次，作为一个加拿大人，在多伦多长大，我，我，你知道，我们非常自豪我们有SCTV，它来自多伦多，我们非常，我们仰望你们。所以你们就是我观看的人，并且能够说，这些家伙做到了。你知道，不是如果这些家伙能做到，我们就能做到，我们仰望你们。嗯，你知道，当你在加拿大或多伦多开始任何事情时，就像我们那样，你，
it has to, like for example, SETV was, you know, we started when SNL came on in, what, 75. Yeah. We came on in 76 because Bernie Solans who owned the Second City Theater back then, you know, just said, well, you know, we're losing all our people to SNL because SNL was kind of, you know, half Second City and half Lampoon basically when they started. So all our, all our people are going to be going to SNL. We should start our own show.
它必须，比如SCTV，你知道，我们开始时SNL是在，什么，75年。是啊。我们在76年开始，因为当时拥有Second City剧院的Bernie Solans，你知道，只是说，嗯，你知道，我们正在失去所有的人才给SNL，因为SNL当时，你知道，基本上是半个Second City和半个Lampoon。所以我们所有的人都要去SNL了。我们应该开始我们自己的节目。
So we came up with the, you know, SETV, Second City Television and, you know, our, while they were the toast of Broadway in New York, you know, we had our budget was $7,000 a show when we, when we started SETV and it was only a Toronto show back in 76. Yeah. And in SETV, in seconds, in SETV, it was you, Catherine O'Hara, John Candy, Marty Short again. Yeah. Again, it was all of these other people that are now just known as comedic, you know.
所以我们想出了，你知道，SCTV，Second City Television，而且，你知道，我们的，当他们是纽约百老汇的宠儿时，你知道，我们，我们的预算是每集7000美元，当我们，当我们开始SCTV时，它在76年只是一个多伦多的节目。是啊。而在SCTV，在Second City，在SCTV里，有你，Catherine O'Hara，John Candy，Marty Short。是啊。再次，又是所有这些现在被称为喜剧，你知道，的人。
Was Martin Moll a part of that? No. No. No, no, no. I met, I met Martin Moll. Well, when we were, when we were working on, well, anyway, I can't, I won't go into that sir. But I met him on a movie.
Martin Mull是其中的一部分吗？不。不。不，不，不。我见过，我见过Martin Mull。嗯，当我们，当我们工作时，嗯，总之，我不能，我不会深入那个，先生。但我是在一部电影上见到他的。
We were both doing a thing called. Are you nervous about serving prison time or something? Yeah. Because we've all been locked up. Well, it's actually, it's actually a funny story, but it was. We're ready. We were working on a, one of those, your Richie Rich things back years ago. And you know, Christmas wish or something, and Richie Rich and the Christmas wish.
我们都在做一件叫。你是在担心坐牢还是什么的吗？是啊。因为我们都被关过。嗯，其实，其实这是一个有趣的故事，但它是。我们准备好了。我们当时在工作，在那些，你们的Richie Rich的东西之一，几年前。你知道，圣诞愿望什么的，Richie Rich和圣诞愿望。
I watch it every year. I was playing, I was playing a professor, Professor Keenbean, and I was playing it as kind of a Brit and a big mustache and very, very excitable, and I was playing them like that with mustache and glasses. And we were on a break on the set one day and I'm sitting beside Martin and looked at him and I said, Martin, what are we doing here? Paying bills. And he said, Hey, it doesn't say asshole on the check.
我每年都看。我当时在演，我在演一个教授，Keenbean教授，我演得像个英国人，留着大胡子，非常，非常兴奋，我就是那样演的，留着胡子和戴着眼镜。有一天我们在片场休息，我坐在Martin旁边，看着他说，Martin，我们在这里做什么？付账单。他说，嘿，支票上没写“混蛋”。
So I, that's really funny. That was meeting Martin. But no, Martin was not a part of that. But it's, but it's like I was saying in Toronto, you know, it's in back in the early 70s. That's like Dan Ackroyd and a girl named Valerie Bromfield and, you know, and John Candy, right? So I mean, these, these, these were, these people were just, I mean, that was kind of the scene back then. And eventually everybody kind of hooked up either on Godspell or, or on Second City.
所以我，那真的很有趣。那是见到Martin。但不，Martin不是其中的一部分。但它，但它就像我在多伦多说的那样，你知道，在70年代初。那就像Dan Ackroyd和一个叫Valerie Bromfield的女孩，你知道，还有John Candy，对吧？所以我的意思是，这些，这些人在当时就是，我的意思是，那就是当时的场景。最终每个人都以某种方式联系在一起，要么是在《Godspell》，要么是在Second City。
And we will be right back. We get support from visible. So guys, you know how hard it is to plan something, right? So right now I'm working on planning a game night. It's super fun, but it's like a lot of work and I'm excited to do it, but it's a little overwhelming. It's just like planning anything, right? I don't know.
我们马上回来。我们得到了Visible的支持。所以伙计们，你们知道计划某事有多难，对吧？所以现在我正在计划一个游戏之夜。超级有趣，但就像很多工作，我很兴奋去做，但有点不知所措。就像计划任何事情一样，对吧？我不知道。
Valentine's Day is coming up. I was like, Oh God, what's the plan? Something's like me and Scotty to do like, can't we just watch TV? Like, I don't know. It's like, it's hard to plan anything, isn't it? So why would I want to be on a kind of like family plan? You know, when it's hard enough for one person, can you imagine everybody chipping in and doing it?
情人节快到了。我当时想，哦天哪，计划是什么？像我和Scotty这样的人要做什么，我们不能只是看电视吗？就像，我不知道。就像，计划任何事情都很难，不是吗？所以我为什么要加入那种家庭计划？你知道，当一个人已经很难了，你能想象每个人都出钱去做吗？
I don't know. It gets, it gets crazy. So today's episode is sponsored by visible who wants to simplify your life by separating your phone from your family. Visible offers their best rate all on one line, not four lines, not three, not even two, just a one line wireless plan with unlimited data for $30 a month taxes and fees included all powered by Verizon. Reach today at visible.com and get 20 bucks off your first month when you use code SMARTLESS20.
我不知道。它变得，它变得疯狂。所以今天的节目由Visible赞助，他们想通过把你的手机从你的家庭中分离出来来简化你的生活。Visible在一条线路上提供他们最好的费率，不是四条线路，不是三条，甚至不是两条，只是一条无线计划，每月30美元无限数据，含税费，全部由Verizon提供支持。今天访问visible.com，使用代码SMARTLESS20，你的第一个月可减免20美元。
That's SMARTLESS20. A special offer for SMARTLESS listeners offer ends March 31st. New activation and offer code required for data management practices learn more at visible.com. Additional terms apply. SmartLess gets support from Diet Coke throughout the whole year, not just Valentine's Day. Diet Coke reminds you to love what you love. So this holiday, embrace the spirit of investing in the most important relationship you have, the one with yourself.
那是SMARTLESS20。给SMARTLESS听众的特别优惠，优惠于3月31日结束。需要新的激活和优惠代码，关于数据管理实践，请在visible.com了解更多。适用附加条款。SmartLess得到了Diet Coke的支持，全年，不仅仅是情人节。Diet Coke提醒你爱其所爱。所以这个节日，拥抱投资于你拥有的最重要关系的这种精神，那就是与你自己的关系。
Self-love is anything but selfish. Diet Coke has been loved for its crisp, refreshing taste for over 40 years. So if you need confidence to make a bold move this Valentine's Day, like taking yourself out to dinner or heading to a movie solo, Diet Coke is the fuel to unapologetically make that move. Diet Coke is the inspiration to stay true to doing things your way and to love what you love. So Valentine's Day isn't everyone's favorite, like why does dinner or flowers matter more
自爱绝非自私。Diet Coke因其清脆、清爽的口感而受到喜爱超过40年。所以如果你需要信心在这个情人节做出大胆的举动，比如带自己出去吃饭或独自去看电影，Diet Coke就是让你毫不妥协地做出那个举动的燃料。Diet Coke是坚持以自己的方式做事并爱其所爱的灵感。所以情人节并不是每个人的最爱，比如为什么晚餐或鲜花在
on February 14th than any other day? I don't get it. For me and Scotty, every day is Valentine's Day, so we don't do anything. Do you know what I mean? However, don't forget to fill your own cup up, especially if you're single or not necessarily looking. And for us, that cup is a glass of Diet Coke. If you need to pick me up to help you make a bold romantic gesture or simply take yourself
2月14日比任何其他日子更重要？我不明白。对于我和Scotty来说，每一天都是情人节，所以我们什么都不做。你知道我的意思吗？然而，别忘了填满你自己的杯子，特别是如果你单身或者不一定在寻找。对我们来说，那个杯子就是一杯Diet Coke。如果你需要提神来帮助你做出大胆的浪漫姿态，或者只是带自己
on a date, Diet Coke is the ultimate partner. So my friends, embrace love this Valentine's Day with Diet Coke and love what you love. SmartList is sponsored by BetterHelp. I'm going to talk about when I feel my best self, when I feel my best self, I am at home and I'm in the safe space of my relationship with Scotty and I can just kind of talk about almost anything. But there are certain things that I like to talk about with a therapist that makes me feel my best self and that helps me get there, right?
去约会，Diet Coke是终极伙伴。所以我的朋友们，在这个情人节拥抱爱，喝Diet Coke，爱其所爱。SmartList由BetterHelp赞助。我要谈谈当我感觉最好的时候，当我感觉最好的时候，我在家里，在我和Scotty的关系的安全空间里，我可以谈论几乎任何事情。但有些事情我喜欢和治疗师谈论，这让我感觉最好的自己，这有助于我达到那个状态，对吧？
Because when you're at your best, you can do great things, but sometimes life gets you bogged down and you may feel overwhelmed or like you're not showing up in the way that you want to. So working with a therapist can help you get closer to the best version of you. Because when you feel empowered, you're more prepared to take on everything life throws at you. So like I have therapy in two hours, right? It was just true from the time I'm recording this.
因为当你处于最佳状态时，你可以做伟大的事情，但有时生活会让你陷入困境，你可能会感到不知所措，或者觉得你没有以你想要的方式表现出来。所以与治疗师合作可以帮助你更接近最好的自己。因为当你感到被赋能时，你更有准备去应对生活抛给你的任何事情。所以就像我在两小时后有治疗，对吧？从我录制这段话的时间来看这是真的。
And I know I always feel better afterwards because those certain things that I can't talk to Scotty about or anybody like a friend that I keep for myself. But I know it's safe to talk to a therapist about it because it's not going anywhere. It's just a conversation between me and her and I get a lot done with that. I get it out of my head and into hers and it always, always helps. So if you're thinking of giving therapy a try, better help is a great option. It's convenient, flexible, affordable and entirely online. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch
我知道我事后总是感觉更好，因为那些我不能和Scotty谈论的事情，或者像朋友那样我为自己保留的事情。但我知道和治疗师谈论它是安全的，因为它不会传出去。这只是我和她之间的对话，我从中得到了很多。我把它从我的脑海里拿出来放进她的脑海里，它总是，总是很有帮助。所以如果你正在考虑尝试治疗，BetterHelp是一个很好的选择。它方便、灵活、实惠且完全在线。只需填写一份简短的问卷，即可与持证治疗师匹配，并随时更换
therapists any time for no additional charge. If you want to live a more empowered life, therapy can get you there. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartlist today to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelphelp.com slash smartlist. And now back to the show. When did you first work with Christopher Guest? Well, I first encountered, well, listen, Chris was, I was a fan of Chris's from the National Lampoon days, you know, when I'd listened to the radio broadcast.
治疗师，无需额外费用。如果你想过上更有力量的生活，治疗可以带你到达那里。今天访问betterhelp.com/smartlist，你的第一个月可享受10%的折扣。那是betterhelp.com/smartlist。现在回到节目。你第一次和Christopher Guest合作是什么时候？嗯，我第一次遇到，嗯，听着，Chris，我是Chris在National Lampoon时期的粉丝，你知道，当我听广播节目时。
And I knew, you know, Bill Murray was on that, Gilda Radner and Paul Schaefer and Harold Ramos and they, you know, but there was a guy who did voices and characters that just blew me away. And I kept thinking, who is this guy? He had the most incredible voice, you know, that kind of deep nasally kind of thing. And his characters were insane. And I laughed so hard and found out that this, this guy's name was Chris Guest. And then I met him on a Billy Crystal special in the mid 80s, 85. But we didn't work together.
我知道，你知道，Bill Murray在里面，Gilda Radner和Paul Schaefer和Harold Ramos，他们，你知道，但有一个家伙做的声音和角色让我大吃一惊。我一直在想，这个家伙是谁？他有最不可思议的声音，你知道，那种深沉的鼻音。他的角色太疯狂了。我笑得太厉害了，发现这个，这个家伙的名字叫Chris Guest。然后我在80年代中期，85年的一个Billy Crystal特别节目中遇到了他。但我们没有一起工作。
But when he was on camera, I made sure I was on set that day. And I would just sit and watch him and try not to laugh and blow the take. I got to work with him again in the late 80s directing one of Marty's specials. I, Martin Short goes Hollywood and Chris was on that working with Marty. They played two gossip columnists and basically improvised their entire rant on camera. And again, it was still the funniest footage that, you know, I have to date. So cut to mid 90s. I get a call in Toronto and it's Chris Guest on the phone.
但当他在镜头前时，我确保那天我在片场。我只是坐着看他，尽量不笑场毁掉拍摄。我在80年代末又和他一起工作，导演了Marty的一个特别节目。我，《Martin Short goes Hollywood》，Chris在上面和Marty一起工作。他们扮演两个八卦专栏作家，基本上在镜头前即兴发挥了他们所有的咆哮。而且再次，那仍然是我迄今为止看过的最有趣的镜头。所以快进到90年代中期。我在多伦多接到一个电话，是Chris Guest打来的。
And he said, I'm thinking of working on a movie. Would you want to, would you want to work on it with me? And I, you know, and I'm, my heart was kind of palpitating over the phone because I. I mean, I didn't know him. I just worked, you know, big fan. Yeah, huge and that movie was well, the movie turned out to be waiting for Guffman said, you know, I've got a cabin up in the Idaho and, you know, we can go up there and work.
他说，我正在考虑拍一部电影。你想，你想和我一起工作吗？我，你知道，我的心在电话那头怦怦直跳，因为我。我的意思是，我不认识他。我只是工作，你知道，大粉丝。是啊，巨大的，那部电影是，嗯，电影结果是《Waiting for Guffman》，他说，你知道，我在爱达荷州有个小屋，你知道，我们可以去那里工作。
And I thought, Jesus, what am I, you know, I don't know this. I trying to get away for the weekend already working in a cabin, working on a script. Yeah, six rules, a duct tape. What's going on? What happens if it doesn't work out? What happens if it's, you know, a nightmare? Yeah, how do I get to the airport? Right.
我想，天哪，我是什么，你知道，我不认识这个。试图在周末逃离，已经在小屋里，在写剧本。是啊，六卷胶带。怎么回事？如果不行怎么办？如果它是，你知道，一场噩梦怎么办？是啊，我怎么去机场？对。
How did he present that project? Did he say it was all going to be improvised or that there was going to be some sort of a loose script or an outline? At the time, he just said, I'm thinking of putting it together. Would you want to help write it? And so I said, what's the worst that can happen if it just, if it's, if it doesn't work out, I just go to the airport and fly home and that's it. So I went there.
他是怎么提出那个项目的？他说一切都会是即兴的，还是会有某种松散的剧本或大纲？当时，他只是说，我正在考虑把它放在一起。你想帮忙写吗？所以我说，最坏的情况能发生什么，如果它，如果它不行，我就去机场飞回家，就这样。所以我去了那里。
I flew there and from the time he picked me up at the airport, to the time we got to the cabin, I was laughing so hard and, you know, and I had him laughing as well and we started working on this thing. And I knew from spinal tap, listen, when I saw spinal tap, I was so envious. Yeah. Right. Of anybody that was in it. It was the most brilliant thing I had ever seen.
我飞到那里，从他去机场接我，到我们到达小屋，我笑得太厉害了，你知道，我也让他笑了，我们开始做这件事。我从《Spinal Tap》就知道，听着，当我看到《Spinal Tap》时，我是多么羡慕。是啊。对。任何在里面的人。那是我见过的最天才的东西。
Good for you for being honest that you were envious. A lot of people would say, I loved it. I loved that you thought you were envious. No, I was envious. Listen, my good friend Paul Schaefer was in it and he's not even an actor. Right. So Eugene, you know, I have to tell you, when I went to go see Waiting for Guffman when it first came out, half, well, I forget the year that it came out, but this is a badge of honor
为你诚实地承认你羡慕而感到高兴。很多人会说，我喜欢它。我喜欢你认为你羡慕。不，我很羡慕。听着，我的好朋友Paul Schaefer在里面，他甚至不是演员。对。所以Eugene，你知道，我必须告诉你，当我第一次去看《Waiting for Guffman》时，一半，嗯，我忘了它上映的年份，但这是一种荣誉
what I'm about to say. Half the theater walked out because they didn't understand that it was improvised. They didn't get the comedy like the, and the other half of the theater was like crying, laughing. I mean, and so it was just interesting. Was this in this country or like far east? It was this country. And then as people caught on and realized, oh, this is an understood the comedy understood
我要说的话。半个剧院的人走了，因为他们不明白它是即兴的。他们没看懂喜剧，就像，另一半剧院的人在哭，在笑。我的意思是，所以这很有趣。这是在这个国家还是远东？这是在这个国家。然后当人们明白过来并意识到，哦，这是理解了喜剧，理解了
the improv, it became this huge, huge hit. You know, but for my sister, Tracy, a lot of it's improvised, right? So it's not a script with, with specific dialogue. It was just an outline saying like this scene will be about this and yeah, Sean, it was this like in Illinois, you can probably hear like the, the 300 ounce Mountain Dews hitting the ground as people stomped out, I'm going to say stomped out or thundered out. But it was really kind of a unique, different style of comedy that people didn't see before. And I think people didn't get it.
即兴表演，它就成了巨大的，巨大的热门。你知道，但对于我姐姐Tracy来说，很多都是即兴的，对吧？所以这不是一个有具体对话的剧本。它只是一个大纲，说比如这个场景将是关于这个的，是啊，Sean，它就像在伊利诺伊州，你可能能听到像300盎司的Mountain Dew撞击地面的声音，当人们跺着脚离开，我要说跺着脚或雷鸣般地离开。但这确实是一种独特的，不同的喜剧风格，人们以前没见过。而且我认为人们没看懂。
And now they do, of course. In the mold of spinal tap, this is what Chris was putting together with Waiting for Guffman. So you know, we did, we put together a very, you know, detailed outline. We, you know, we lay out the story, we lay out all the story points scene by scene so that it moves, you know, otherwise it's like, it's just a free for all of improvisation and like, you know, you're in trouble and, you know, you can't pay an editor enough money. You have to have an idea, you have to have an idea of where you're going and what your objective is.
现在他们当然懂了。在《Spinal Tap》的模子里，这就是Chris在《Waiting for Guffman》中放在一起的东西。所以你知道，我们做了，我们放在一起了一个非常，你知道，详细的大纲。我们，你知道，我们列出了故事，我们逐个场景列出了所有的故事点，这样它就会移动，你知道，否则它就像，它只是即兴表演的自由放任，就像，你知道，你有麻烦了，而且，你知道，你付给剪辑师再多的钱也不够。你必须有一个想法，你必须有一个关于你要去哪里以及你的目标是什么的想法。
Yeah. So, so we laid everything out, but what, and, and, and if we had some funny lines, we would put them in the script if we thought it was funny, but, but we didn't hold anybody to saying them. We just, we put that in, but more or less how the information came out was up to the, the brilliant cast. So the script would basically be, this, this is what the scene should be about. This information should be revealed in this scene.
是啊。所以，所以我们列出了一切，但什么，而且，而且，如果我们有一些有趣的台词，如果觉得有趣，我们会把它们放进剧本里，但是，但我们没有强迫任何人说它们。我们只是，我们放进去了，但信息是如何出来的或多或少取决于，那个天才的演员阵容。所以剧本基本上是，这，这就是场景应该关于什么的。这个信息应该在这个场景中揭示。
Yes. Yes. Corky walks into rehearsal very upset because he's, you know, one of the great characters of all time. Of all time. Of all times. Really. And you know, it's so funny.
是的。是的。Corky走进排练非常心烦，因为他是，你知道，史上最伟大的角色之一。史上最伟大的。史上最伟大的。真的。而且你知道，这太有趣了。
Catherine, I was just talking to Catherine O'Hara the other day and she was telling me, because I was like, how, when you made those movies, I was asking her, did you guys not just break up laughing constantly? Because I would have been on the floor and she goes, she told me, I don't know. If it was that or best in show where she, you did, she said, I, she did something, somebody did something that made you laugh so hard, but you didn't want to ruin the take. So you crawled out of the scene on your, on your knees, being on the floor. Yeah.
Catherine，我前几天刚和Catherine O'Hara谈过，她告诉我，因为我当时想，当你们拍那些电影时，我问她，你们难道没有一直笑场吗？因为我会倒在地上的，她说，她告诉我，我不知道。如果是那个或者《Best in Show》，你，你，她说，我，她做了什么，有人做了什么让你笑得太厉害了，但你不想毁掉拍摄。所以你跪在地上爬出了场景。是啊。
That, that was in Guffman and that was of course Corky. That was Chris and he had this, you know, you remember the dance move he had with his pants on backwards. Yes. Of course. He would kind of. Yeah. Yeah.
那，那是在《Guffman》里，那当然是Corky。那是Chris，他有这个，你知道，你记得他裤子穿反了的那个舞蹈动作吗？是的。当然。他会那种。是啊。是啊。
That thing. Yeah. Like every time and I, I just could not stop laughing. So there's a scene in the movie where he's teaching us choreography and he, and every time he makes this move, I go crazy and I start laughing. So I worked my way to the back of the group so I could hide behind them. And then I was actually still gut laughing so hard that I dropped to my knees and I crawled off the set so that they could keep shooting and nobody, you know what I mean?
那个东西。是啊。就像每次，我，我就是无法停止笑。所以电影里有一个场景，他在教我们编舞，他，每次他做这个动作，我就疯了，我开始笑。所以我努力退到人群后面，这样我就可以躲在他们后面。然后我实际上仍然笑得太厉害了，以至于我跪在地上，我爬出了片场，这样他们就可以继续拍摄，没有人，你知道我的意思吗？
It's a group scene. It didn't matter. That's hysterical. That's so good. But that troupe that you guys cultivated, curated, all those actors, you guys went on to do a few movies together. How many? I mean, I wish you guys would just keep going and going.
这是一个集体场景。没关系。那太搞笑了。那太好了。但你们培养的那个剧团，策划的，所有那些演员，你们一起拍了几部电影。多少部？我的意思是，我希望你们能一直拍下去。
Mighty winds, Best in Show, Guffman. For your consideration. Wow. It occurs to me, Eugene, that you, if you think about, it just occurs to me like looking back at starting with Godspell and then Second City, SCTV, and then working with Chris Guest and that whole crew that you really, it seems to me, and you can tell me if this is right, you enjoy working and collaborating in an ensemble that you get a lot out of that process and you really shine in an ensemble.
《Mighty Winds》，《Best in Show》，《Guffman》。《For Your Consideration》。哇。Eugene，我突然想到，你，如果你想想，我突然想到，回顾从《Godspell》开始，然后是Second City，SCTV，然后和Chris Guest以及整个团队合作，你真的，在我看来，你可以告诉我这是否正确，你喜欢在一个你从那个过程中得到很多，并且你在合奏中真正闪耀的合奏中工作和协作。
Even the show you did with your son, which I want to get to, with Dan, that you love being part of almost like a troupe each time, there's a similarity there that you create to community. Do you enjoy that? Does that make you, does that invigorate you? Oh yeah. Yeah. Well, of course.
即使是你和你儿子一起做的节目，我想谈谈，和Dan一起，你喜欢成为一个剧团的一部分，每次都有相似之处，你创造了社区。你喜欢那个吗？那让你，那让你振奋吗？哦，是啊。是啊。嗯，当然。
It, to be a part of it, energizes you. You've all had that experience. I mean, you guys, you know, Will and Grace must have been like that, Arrested Development must have been like that. Yeah, it was super fun. You know, it's, you enjoy watching other people doing their thing. Yeah, it's fun. Yeah, and it's infectious.
它，成为它的一部分，让你充满活力。你们都有过那种经历。我的意思是，你们，你知道，《Will and Grace》一定像那样，《Arrested Development》一定像那样。是啊，超级有趣。你知道，你喜欢看别人做他们的事情。是啊，很有趣。是啊，而且很有感染力。
One plus one makes three. Yeah. The whole group. It's, it's insane and it's kind of fun, it's fun work. Those movies were, were fun work because you never really know what, you know, what's going to happen. When we did Guffman, my first scene, even though we were writing it and I knew it was an improvised movie, my first day of shooting, when I got to where Austin, we were shooting
一加一等于三。是啊。整个团队。它，它太疯狂了，而且这是一种有趣的，有趣的工作。那些电影是，是有趣的工作，因为你永远不知道，你知道，会发生什么。当我们拍《Guffman》时，我的第一个场景，尽管我们在写它，而且我知道这是一部即兴电影，我拍摄的第一天，当我到达Austin，我们在拍摄
in Texas, Lockhart, Texas actually was the town. We got there and I'm, I'm ready to shoot my scene. I go in and then I say to Chris, so where do you want to rehearse? He said, what do you mean? I said, well, where do you want to go over the scene? Where do you want to, where should we work it out? What, what do you mean? Yeah.
在德克萨斯州，其实是Lockhart，德克萨斯州那个镇。我们到了那里，我，我准备拍我的场景。我进去，然后我对Chris说，那么你想在哪里排练？他说，你什么意思？我说，嗯，你想在哪里过一遍场景？你想在哪里，我们应该在哪里解决它？什么，你什么意思？是啊。
I said, just to rehearse the scene, he said, no, the cameras are there. We're going to be doing it on camera. First take. First take. I said, oh, oh, okay, so we do it just on camera. Right. Yeah. Okay.
我说，只是为了排练场景，他说，不，摄像机在那里。我们要在镜头前做。第一条。第一条。我说，哦，哦，好的，所以我们只是在镜头前做。对。是啊。好的。
No practicing. And that, you know, but that, that becomes a very kind of joyous experience because you don't know what's going to happen. You don't know what people are necessarily going to say, how they're going to say it, what's going to happen. And kind of, and holding it together is, is kind of a key thing. We learned over the, over the number of movies that as much as you want to laugh like we did in Guffman because it was just so much fun.
不练习。而且那个，你知道，但那，那变成了一种非常，你知道，快乐的体验，因为你不知道会发生什么。你不知道人们一定会说什么，他们会怎么说，会发生什么。而且那种，而且把它保持在一起是，是关键的事情。我们在多部电影中了解到，尽管你想笑，就像我们在《Guffman》中那样，因为它太有趣了。
It was like kids, kids at school, you know, doing a play. What is your secret? Do you have a, do you have a secret trick not to laugh? I mean, I, I like to drive a nail into my, my fingernail into my leg a little bit. But I want to hear, I want to hear Eugene's trick because I know what Jason's real one is. Go ahead Eugene. I, I wouldn't, you know what the thing is, I think, I think it's just bearing the brunt
就像学校里的孩子们在排演话剧一样。你有什么秘诀吗？你有什么不笑的独门绝技吗？我是说，我喜欢往腿上掐一下，指甲掐进肉里那种。但我很想听听尤金的秘诀，因为我知道杰森真正的秘诀是什么。尤金，你来吧。我，我不会，你知道吗，我觉得，我觉得这只是在承受后果。
of how disappointing it would be if there's a great take happening and you blow it by laughing and when you're improvising a scene, you will never get that exact moment again. You know, it just won't happen again. So if you're the one that blows it, you're going to have to go back and do it. And are you going to get the same thing? Probably not. So there's a moment that's gone. So just the guilt factor alone.
如果正在拍摄一段精彩的戏，却因为你笑场而搞砸了，那种失望感是巨大的。当你即兴表演一个场景时，你永远无法再重现那一刻了。你知道，它就是不会再发生了。所以如果你是那个搞砸的人，你就得回去重拍。你还能拍出同样的效果吗？可能不会。所以那一刻就永远消失了。单单是这种负罪感就够受的了。
And it wasn't your moment by definition. You know, you're laughing at what someone else is creating and you're wrecking their creation. Yeah. Sometimes, you know, it's, if it's my moment, I, there's a possibility I might laugh because I, I surprised myself and I, I can't really hold back. It'd be great if you say, and it was my moment because I, because I'm my biggest fan and I enjoy my work.
而且那本来就不是你的高光时刻。你知道，你在笑别人创造的东西，你在破坏他们的创作。是的。有时候，如果是我的高光时刻，我可能会笑，因为我给了自己惊喜，我真的忍不住。如果你能说“那是我的高光时刻”会很棒，因为我是我最大的粉丝，我很享受我的工作。
I enjoy my work. Yeah. We'll be right back. We'd like to thank Helix for supporting the show. So I talked about this before. I got the Helix Dusk Luxe mattress, not only before the comfiness of that mattress, but I like saying the name Helix Dusk Luxe. But what I love about the Helix Dusk Luxe mattress is that my dog, my dog Ricky sleeps
我很享受我的工作。好的，我们马上回来。我们要感谢 Helix 对本节目的支持。我之前提到过这个。我买了 Helix Dusk Luxe 床垫，不仅是因为它非常舒适，我还喜欢说“Helix Dusk Luxe”这个名字。但我喜欢 Helix Dusk Luxe 床垫的原因是我的狗，我的狗瑞奇睡在
on the bed and like he's a hundred pounds, the dog, and he spreads out everywhere. Because I was always, always worried right when I got the mattress and the dog, I was like, oh God, I'm never going to sleep. We both, you can walk in any night and find both of us snoring like crazy. Like so it's not just for me. It's actually Ricky sleeps great on the bed too. It's true. Helix Sleep is a premium mattress brand that provides tailored mattresses based on your
床上，它有一百磅重，它到处乱躺。因为我刚买床垫和养狗的时候总是很担心，我想，天哪，我永远也睡不着了。我们俩，你任何时候走进去都能发现我们俩在打呼噜。所以这不仅仅是为了我。其实瑞奇在床上也睡得很好。这是真的。Helix Sleep 是一个高端床垫品牌，根据你
unique sleep preferences. The Helix lineup includes 14 unique mattresses, including a collection of luxury models, a mattress for big and tall sleepers, and even a mattress made just for kids. Everybody is unique and everyone sleeps differently. That's why Helix has several different mattress models to choose from, each designed for specific sleep positions and feel preferences. So how will you know which Helix mattress works best for you and your body? Take the Helix Sleep Quiz and find your perfect mattress in under two minutes and your personalized
独特的睡眠偏好提供定制床垫。Helix 系列包括 14 款独特的床垫，包括一系列豪华款、为高大体型人士设计的床垫，甚至还有专为儿童设计的床垫。每个人都是独一无二的，每个人的睡眠方式也不同。这就是为什么 Helix 有多种不同的床垫型号可供选择，每一种都针对特定的睡眠姿势和舒适度偏好而设计。那么你如何知道哪款 Helix 床垫最适合你和你的身体呢？参加 Helix 睡眠测试，在两分钟内找到你的完美床垫，你的个性化
mattress is shipped straight to your door free of charge. Helix knows there's no better way to test out a new mattress than by sleeping on it in your own home. That's why they offer a hundred night risk-free trial. Helix is offering up to $350 off all mattress orders and two free pillows for our listeners. Go to helixsleep.com slash smartlist. This is their best offer yet and it won't last long with Helix Better Sleep Starts Now. We're brought to you in part by Zip Recruiter.
床垫将免费直接送到你家门口。Helix 知道，测试新床垫最好的方法就是在自己家里睡一睡。这就是为什么他们提供 100 晚无风险试睡。Helix 为我们的听众提供所有床垫订单最高 350 美元的折扣，并赠送两个免费枕头。请访问 helixsleep.com/smartlist。这是他们迄今为止最好的优惠，而且不会持续太久，有了 Helix，更好的睡眠从现在开始。本节目部分由 Zip Recruiter 提供支持。
So in honor of Valentine's Day this month, it's kind of like important to factor in all the things and when you're trying to find the right person, right, and they're being in the right relationship, you look for personality or humor or obviously attraction or loyalty or trust or similar life goals and values, like all that stuff, right? Too bad there's not some sort of technology that can easily find the right person for you. But if you're hiring, there is technology that can quickly help you find the right person for your open role Zip Recruiter's matching technology.
为了庆祝本月的情人节，在寻找合适的人选时，考虑所有因素是很重要的，对吧？在一段合适的感情中，你会寻找个性、幽默感，或者显而易见的吸引力、忠诚、信任，或者相似的人生目标和价值观，所有这些，对吧？可惜没有某种技术可以轻松为你找到合适的人。但如果你正在招聘，确实有一种技术可以快速帮你找到适合空缺职位的人选，那就是 Zip Recruiter 的匹配技术。
And right now you can try it for free at ZipRecruiter.com slash smartlist. How does Zip Recruiter help you meet desirable candidates? Well, Zip Recruiter uses smart matching technology to identify the most qualified people for a wide range of roles. If you see the one, Zip Recruiter makes it easy to send them a personal invite so they're more likely to apply to your job. Want to really catch their eye? Zip Recruiter offers a tangent grabbing labels that speak to job flexibility like urgent,
现在你可以在 ZipRecruiter.com/smartlist 免费试用。Zip Recruiter 如何帮你找到理想的候选人？嗯，Zip Recruiter 使用智能匹配技术来识别最符合各种职位的合格人选。如果你看到了心仪的人，Zip Recruiter 可以让你轻松发送个人邀请，这样他们更有可能申请你的职位。想真正吸引他们的眼球吗？Zip Recruiter 提供吸引人的标签，说明工作的灵活性，比如“紧急”、“提供培训”、“远程”等等。
training provided, remote, and more. Find candidates you're crazy about with Zip Recruiter. Employers love Zip Recruiter. In fact, four out of five employers who post on Zip Recruiter get a quality candidate within the first day. See for yourself. Go to this exclusive web address to try Zip Recruiter for free ZipRecruiter.com slash smartlist.
用 Zip Recruiter 找到让你心动的候选人。雇主们喜欢 Zip Recruiter。事实上，五分之四在 Zip Recruiter 上发布职位的雇主在第一天内就能获得高质量的候选人。亲自去看看吧。访问这个专属网址免费试用 Zip Recruiter：ZipRecruiter.com/smartlist。
Again, that's ZipRecruiter.com slash smartlist. Zip Recruiter the smartest way to hire. And now back to the show. I would like to know, I would like to talk about what we're not talking about, which is Schitt's Creek. I know why I was getting moved. This is all the build up. You created a show, one of your great sensations with your son, Dan.
再说一遍，是 ZipRecruiter.com/smartlist。Zip Recruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。现在回到节目。我想知道，我想谈谈我们还没谈过的话题，那就是《富家穷路》。我知道我为什么会被感动。这都是铺垫。你和你的儿子丹一起创作了一部剧，那是你们的伟大成就之一。
And it's one of the greatest comedies of all time now. And I've been sitting here since you got on, want to talk about it. And I want to know how it happened, because I love Dan, Dan's like such a, he's you. He's like sweet, normal, hilarious, funny, great, outgoing, like everybody loves him, everybody loves you. So how did that happen? I can't confirm because I haven't met him yet, but it sounds right. He seems nice.
现在它是有史以来最伟大的喜剧之一。自从你坐下，我就一直想谈谈它。我想知道它是怎么发生的，因为我爱丹，丹就像，他就是你。他甜美、正常、搞笑、风趣、伟大、外向，每个人都爱他，每个人都爱你。那是怎么发生的？我无法确认，因为我还没见过他，但听起来很对。他看起来人不错。
Well, once you meet him, I'd love to get your take on him, though. And if you could let Eugene know what you think of his son, too, that'd be nice of you. I'll put it up on my blog. What a fucking dick. Quick review, Eugene. No, he's done, he has, I have to say, both my kids have all the talent that the dad didn't quite have. But...
嗯，等你见到他，我很想听听你对他的看法。如果你能让尤金知道你对他儿子的看法，那就太好了。我会把它发在我的博客上。真是个混蛋。快速点评一下，尤金。不，他完成了，我必须说，我的两个孩子拥有我父亲所不具备的所有天赋。但是……
BS, I'm calling BS. Yeah, he's really quite amazing. And we started this thing, you know, when he said, do you want to work on a show? I, you know, I said, yeah, yeah, that would be good. I didn't, I never thought that would happen. So, but that was good. And it was watching, it was like watching him, and no matter what happened, I, it was the experience of doing this with him, that I thought, okay, this is probably a once in a
胡说，我说是胡说。是的，他真的很棒。我们开始做这件事的时候，你知道，当他说“你想一起做一个节目吗？”我，你知道，我说“好啊，那会很棒”。我没，我从没想过那会发生。所以，但这很好。看着他，无论发生什么，我，和他一起经历这件事，我想，好吧，这可能是一生中
lifetime thing, just make, you know, make the most of it, enjoy it. This is great. Never thought it would happen. And so we start working on this, and then, you know, I had, at one point, I had a nightmare. I woke up in a cold sweat thinking, what if he doesn't have it? Oh, sure, sure. At what point, I mean, we're going to keep working on this, this idea. Face replacement.
只有一次的事情，只要，你知道，充分利用它，享受它。这太棒了。从没想过会发生。所以我们开始做这个，然后，你知道，我有一次，我做了一个噩梦。我冷汗直流地醒来，心想，如果他没有天赋怎么办？哦，当然，当然。在某个时刻，我是说，我们要继续做这个，这个想法。换脸。
If I know that he doesn't quite have what it takes, how long are we going to keep working on this as a project, or at what point do I sit him down, and do I tell him he just doesn't have it? Sure. Yeah, it's a tough call. You know? Or do we, or do we just keep working away, thinking, you know, kind of, you know, where he's kind of deluding himself.
如果我知道他没有那个能力，我们还要把这个项目做多久，或者在什么时刻我该坐下来告诉他他就是不行？当然。是的，这是一个艰难的决定。你知道吗？或者我们，或者我们只是继续做下去，心想，你知道，他有点在自欺欺人。
Right. And, you know, you think Sophie had a choice. Yeah. Wow. Wow. So I decided, but anyway, his work was, his writing was great, his ideas were great. And so that never really happened. And when we got to the point of starting the show, he really, really exploded in terms
对。而且，你知道，你以为索菲有选择吗。哇。哇。所以我决定，但无论如何，他的工作很棒，他的想法很棒。所以那种情况从未真正发生。当我们开始制作这部剧时，他在表演方面，在写作方面，还有他的制作技能方面，真的，真的爆发了。我是说，太，你做得太搞笑了。我记得从试播集开始看，一直看到最后，尤其是第一季，去了解并看到所有这些动作，看到它有多好笑，只是心想，天哪，这太棒了，但是，是什么时刻，也许甚至不是通过你自己的视角，你，你还记得有其他人，你认识或尊敬的人，或者你共事过的人，他们接触到了素材或这部剧，有没有人停下来对你说，嘿，尤金，嘿，
of performing, in terms of writing, and then his producing skills in as well. I mean, it's so, you're doing so funny. I remember watching just from the first episode of the pilot episode, all the way through that, especially that first season, just getting to know and seeing all these moves and seeing how funny it was, and just thinking, God, this is so good, and what, but what was the moment that maybe, maybe not even through your own lens, did you, do you remember kind of somebody else that you knew or respected or you worked with, and they were exposed to the material or to the show, and did anybody stop and say to you like, hey, Eugene, hey,
这真的很棒，伙计。你们真的搞出名堂了，你，你还记得那样的时刻吗？我记得大概在第四或第五集的时候，是其中一集。听着，当我看到这些剧集整合在一起时，我激动得要死，我知道它很好，然后在大约第四或第五集的时候，我知道它真的很好。这是一件非常有趣的事情。对我来说，这是一件在很多层面上都行得通的事情，其中很大一部分与演员阵容有关，选对了人，选到了完美的亚历克西斯，当然，凯瑟琳
this is really good, man. You guys are onto something really, did you, do you remember a moment like that? I remember probably around the fourth or fifth episode, it was one of the shows. Listen, I was thrilled to death when I saw these shows coming together, and I knew it was good, and then around the fourth or fifth show, I knew it was really good. This is something that is really interesting. This is something that is working on so many levels to me, and a lot of it had to do with the cast, just picking the right people, picking just the perfect Alexis, and of course, Catherine
一直是我们饰演莫伊拉的第一人选。我是说，凯瑟琳太不可思议了，我是说，凯瑟琳·欧哈拉真是那种令人难以置信的代际天才，还有伟大的，安妮·墨菲，太棒了，还有你的女儿萨拉，以及所有这些人。我是说，每一个部分都配合得天衣无缝。现在，你和丹尼尔一起制作了这个系列，取得了巨大的成功。你们非常成功，你们把它卖到了全世界，你们做得非常好，你们和加拿大广播公司（CBC）作为合作伙伴，CBC 和南边的 Pop 频道，但这对你们来说是一笔很棒的
was always our first choice for Moira. I mean, Catherine is so incredibly, I mean, what an unbelievable sort of generational talent, Catherine O'Hara, and then the great, and Annie Murphy, so great, and your daughter Sarah, and all these people. I mean, it was just every piece of it worked. Now, so you do this series with Daniel, tremendous success. You guys tremendous, you sell it around the world, you guys do really well, and you make it with the CBC as your partner CBC and pop down here in the States, but it's a great
交易，你们可以更多地控制这个资产，因为你们有这种分成协议，你们能够做到，这真的是一个非常伟大的成功故事，你们为了做到这一点付出了很多。你们在加拿大拍摄，你们在哪里拍摄的？在荒郊野外吗？你们是在萨尼亚还是什么地方？我们的工作室在多伦多，我们的外景地在多伦多以北大约一小时车程的地方，但是的，我们很幸运。那是哪个镇？
deal for you guys, and you guys get to control the property a little bit more because you have this split deal, and you're able to do, and just really, a really great story of success, and you guys put yourselves on the line to do it. You shoot it up in Canada, where were you shooting? In the middle of nowhere, were you in Sarnia or something? Our studio is in Toronto, and our location was about an hour north of Toronto, but yeah, we were fortunate. What town was that?
多伦多以北的那个镇叫什么？那是一个叫古德伍德的小镇。当然，古德伍德。是的，当然，是的。我会在那里买个地方。是的。你还记得那个吗？是的，但是肖恩的网站，你不是有一个类似的评分网站吗？
What town was that north of Toronto? It's a town called Goodwood. Sure, Goodwood. Yeah, sure, yeah. I'll get a place there. Yeah. You remember that one? Yeah, but Sean's website, don't you have a website that's similar to that with a rating?
就像一个评分网站。我忘了是什么了。不管怎样，我忘了是什么了。它真的很棒。有很多上传内容。但你在那里。你们去那里，你们在多伦多拍摄这个东西，你们真的在某种程度上赌上了自己，对吧？
It's like a rating website. I forget what it is. Anyway, I forget what it is. It's really good. A lot of uploads. But you're up there. You guys go up there, you're shooting this thing in Toronto, and you really kind of bet on yourselves in a way, right?
我是说，你们……嗯，老实说，我们只是在做这个节目。我们能让这个节目播出就是全部了。这就是我们关心的全部。我们终于做到了。我们让节目播出了。感觉太好了。然后节目就是你在节目中尽你所能做到最好，幸运的是，
I mean, you guys... Well, to be honest, we're just doing the show. The idea that we got the show on the air was it. That's all we cared about. We finally did it. We got a show on the air. It felt so good. And then the show was you're doing the best job you can on the show, and fortunately,
我们从电视网那里得到的意见很少，最后甚至没有意见。是的。所以，是的，当囚犯能管理疯人院时总是很有趣。嗯，CBC，什么意见……我是说，你们和谁搭档？我想是在《海滩客》之后，我忘了……《海滩客》。
we were getting very few and then eventually no notes from the network. Yeah. So, yes, it's always fun when the inmates can run the asylum. Well, the CBC, what notes... I mean, who are you guys paired with? You were right after the beachcomers, I think. I forget what the... The beachcomers.
《海滩客》。什么？你忘了你和谁搭档了。是的。那要追溯到很久以前了。那要追溯到很久以前了。我知道，但听着，高管们在做他们的工作，他们觉得他们必须做他们的工作。
The beachcomers. What? You forgot where you got paired with there. Yeah. That goes back a while. That goes back a while. I know, but listen, executives are doing their job and they feel like they have to do their job.
所以，他们会带着……带着意见来。他们会带着意见来。其实，你知道吗？CBC，我喜欢那里的那些人。他们一直非常……他们是好人。救场救得好。
So, they're going to come in with... With notes. They're going to come in with notes. Actually, you know what? The CBC, I like those people up there. They've been very... They're nice people. Good save.
谢谢。但是，我是说，老实说，再一次，我是说，你们制作了这么多伟大的季节，你们做到了，你们赢得了所有这些赞誉，这是当之无愧的，我只是……嗯……你再高兴不过了。现在……抱歉，你继续。我本来想说，你一直非常友善，威尔。
Thank you. But, I mean, honestly, once again, I mean, you guys did so many great seasons and you did and you won all these accolades and so well-deserved and I'm just... Well... You couldn't be happier. Now... Sorry, go ahead. I was going to say, you've been awfully kind, Will.
你参加了我们的《最美好的祝愿》纪录片，对这部剧说了非常可爱的话。嗯，我喜欢它。所以，那是……我是个大粉丝。我一直很欣赏这一点。我是你、你儿子丹尼尔和你整个家庭的大粉丝，你们做得非常棒。
You took part in our Best Wishes documentary, had just very lovely things to say about the show. Well, I love it. So, that was... I'm a big fan. I always appreciated that. I'm a big fan of yours and your son Daniels and your whole family, and you guys have done an awesome job.
所以，但现在你正在为 Apple Plus 制作一个新节目，叫《不情愿的旅行者》，这是……我喜欢你的表情，因为你就像，是的，我感觉到你确实是一个不情愿的旅行者。是的。我不喜欢旅行，当他们最初打电话给我谈这个时，他们推销的是一个关于酒店的节目。它叫《窗外有风景》，我接到经纪人的电话说，你知道，他们
So, but then now you're doing this new show for Apple Plus called The Reluctant Traveler, which is... I love your face because you're like, yeah, I get the sense that you are legitimately a reluctant traveler. Yeah. I don't love traveling and when they called me about this, originally, they had pitched a show about hotels. It was called Room with a View and I got a call from my agent saying, you know, they
想让你……苹果想让你主持……他们对你主持这个关于世界各地酒店的节目很感兴趣。然后我说，哦，哇，好吧，这很有趣。所以这是一个关于酒店的节目。我喜欢好的酒店，但你要做很多旅行，然后还有摄像机，所以你必须……然后你还要做……
want you to... Apple wants you to host... They're interested in you hosting this show about hotels all over the world. And I went, oh, wow, okay, that's interesting. So it's a show about hotels. I love a good hotel, but you're doing a lot of traveling and then there's cameras so you got to... And then you're doing...
所以这涉及到一些谈话，然后你必须和人交谈，你通常必须表现得有点活泼和轻快，我在现实生活中不是这样，但我并不认为这是现实生活，所以我说，好吧，非常感谢他们，但我老实说认为他们找错人了。可能有人比我更擅长这个。所以此时，你是一个不情愿的主持人。不错。我是一个不情愿的主持人。
So there's some talking involved and then you have to talk to people and you've got to generally be kind of bubbly and jettie, which I'm not in real life, but I don't consider this real life, so I said, well, thank them very much, but I honestly think they have the wrong guy. There's probably somebody who's much better at this than I am. So at this point, you're being the reluctant host. Nice. I'm being a reluctant host.
是的，抱歉让你继续。我只是表现得普遍不情愿。普遍不情愿。是的。与此同时，你拒绝了他们，他们却说，他是完美的人选。所以发生的事情是，他们又打来电话说，他们真的很想和你谈谈。我说，老实说，我不明白。
Yeah, sorry to keep you going. I'm just being generally reluctant. Reluctant in general. Yeah. Meanwhile, you turning it down and they were like, he's the perfect guy. So what happened was, so they called back again saying, they really want to talk to you. I said, honestly, I don't understand.
重点是什么，好吧，安排通话，我可以亲自告诉他们，因为这是……所以我们安排了通话，我告诉他们为什么我只是……我不是那个人。我不喜欢……我不喜欢……我的饮食口味很正常。我只是那种吃肉和土豆的人。我不喜欢花哨的东西。这是旅行。我真的不喜欢观光，这让我很累。
What the point is, okay, set up the call and I can tell them myself, because this is... So we set up the call and I'm telling them why I just... I'm not the guy. I don't love...I don't love...my food palette is quite normal. I'm just a meat and potatoes kind of. I'm not into fancy things. It's traveling. I don't really love sightseeing, wars me.
我不喜欢水。别让我靠近水。我听到笑声，我得到了笑声。我想，嗯，这太棒了，因为我实际上是在……我表达了我的观点，而且我保持轻松，这不是沉重的。你没意识到你是在给自己选角吗？没错。他们挂了电话。
I'm not big on water. I don't get me near water. And I'm hearing laughs and I'm getting laughs. And I'm thinking, well, this is great because I'm actually getting...I'm making my point and I'm keeping it light and it's not a heavy. Little did you realize you're casting yourself? That's right. They get off the phone.
他搞定了。我后来才知道，那两个，执行制片人和苹果公司的高管，他们说……制片人说，这就是节目。不是关于酒店，忘了酒店吧。这就是节目。那个不想旅行却在做所有旅行的人。所以他们回电并推销了这个，我……我是说，我明白了，你知道吗？因为我不能假装成我不是的那种旅行者。
He mailed it. I found out after and the two, the executive producer and the executive from Apple, they said...the producer said, that's the show. It's not about forget hotels. That's the show. It's the guy that doesn't want to travel that's doing all the traveling. So then they called back and they pitched that and I...I mean, I got that, you know? Because I can't pretend to be the traveler that I'm not.
但如果我是我现在的这种旅行者，而且我在镜头前，但尽管如此……但这需要你现在去旅行。所以你一直在做那个？多少……是的？哦，这……这真的很棒。这是一个非常了不起的节目。所以他们尝试……我们去了世界各地的八个地方，去了马尔代夫，你知道吗？
But if I'm the traveler that I am and I'm on camera, but nevertheless... But it necessitates you now traveling. And so you've been doing that? How many...yes? Oh, it's been...it's been really great. It's been quite a phenomenal show to do. So they try...we've been to eight locations around the world, went to the Maldives, you know?
我什么时候去？我什么时候会去马尔代夫？最好的地方？最好的地方？最差的地方？是的。我……我们确实去了威尼斯，我以前没去过，但我去过意大利。所以我爱意大利。
When am I going? When would I ever go to the Maldives? Best place? Best place? Worst place? Yeah. I...we did go to Venice where I've never been, but I've been to Italy. So I love Italy.
我崇拜。我爱意大利。我只是，你知道，意大利的任何地方，我都绝对喜欢。所以你已经……我是说，这太棒了。多么令人难以置信的职业生涯。你已经做了……老实说，你只是……你做了这么多，而且你还在继续做这么多。而且，你知道，我刚才在想，每次我见到像你这样的人，尤金，那些和同样的人一起工作，和你的朋友共事一辈子的人，我总是想你是多么幸运。
I adore. I love Italy. I just, you know, anywhere in Italy, I absolutely love it. So you've been...I mean, this is great. What an unbelievable career. You've done...honestly, you've just...you've done so much and you continue to do so much. And, you know, I was just thinking, every time I meet people like you, Eugene, who work with the same people and work with your friends your whole life, I always think about how lucky
然后它让我想起……我今天早上在想，当我下来录音时，知道我在录你，我在想，我太幸运了，我能和这些家伙一起做这件事。我爱这些家伙，我能做这个。这是多么……多么令人难以置信的特权，你知道吗？是的。嗯，这是最热门的播客。
you are. And then it reminds me of how...I was thinking this morning, as I was coming down here to record, knowing that I was recording you, and I was thinking, I'm so lucky that I get to do this with these guys. I love these guys, and I get to do this. And what a...what an unbelievable privilege, you know? Yeah. Well, it's the hottest podcast.
那是真的。这是一个热门阵容。我是说，你拥有……好吧。我们就说那是真的，威尔。你正在做……你知道，因为这一切都传达出来了，你在谈论的事情正在传达出来，你知道吗？你们对彼此的感情传达出来了。
That's true. It's a hot cast. I'm saying, you got... All right. Let's just say that's true, Will. You're doing...you know, because it all comes through, what you're talking about is coming through, you know? Your affection for each other comes through.
你们互相拆台的方式也传达出来了，这是……嗯，你怎么能……再一次，你怎么能不呢？这很容易。嗯，看，我是说……我是说，这简直不可思议。我是说，这些家伙简直是……这些家伙简直是彻头彻尾的傻瓜。但也很有趣。
And how you rip each other apart comes through as well, which is... Well, how can you...again, how can you not? It's pretty easy. Well, look, I mean... I mean, it's just unbelievable. I mean, these guys are just... These guys are just complete fools. Also great fun.
尤金，非常感谢。祝你继续……天哪，继续成功，我的朋友，从一个加拿大人到另一个加拿大人。继续加油，嗯？做得好。做得好。感谢这么多令人惊叹的东西，是的，祝你一切顺利，伙计，祝贺你的新节目。
Eugene, thank you so much. Just continued... God, continued success, my friend, from one Canadian to another. Keep her going, eh? Good on you. Good on you. Thanks for so much amazing stuff, and yeah, just all the best, man, and congrats on the new show.
是的。谢谢。谢谢，尤金。谢谢。是的。希望它能成功。它会成功的。很高兴见到你。
Yeah. Thank you. Thanks, Eugene. Thanks. Yes. Hope it works. It's going to work. Great to meet you.
明天见。再见。那么你们明天是拼车去马丁家吃晚饭吗，肖恩，还是你们各自过去？这可能是……我可能会顺路去接他们。我刚才在想，如果我在城里……哦，你会去的。你可能现在就在那里布置了。
I'll see you tomorrow. Bye-bye. So do you guys carpool to Martin's dinner tomorrow, Sean, or do you use Meet There? Which is probably... I'll probably swing by and pick them up. I was just thinking that if I was in town... Oh, you'd be there. You'd be there setting up probably right now.
我可能会在那里。是的，是的，是的。布置。是的。我不会在那里工作，你这个混蛋。我在拆除。如果我在马蒂家做餐饮该多好。顺便说一句，自从《谁杀了圣诞老人：默德维尔》出来后，我就没和你们俩谈过，而且
I'd probably be there. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Setting up. Yeah. I'm not going to work there, you dick. I'm tearing down. How great would it be if I just did catering at Marty's house? By the way, I haven't talked to you both since Who Killed Santa Murderville came out, and
我很抱歉对听众说。这可能是几个月后了，但我只想说祝贺，威利。你们，你和你整个团队，他们制作了一个非常棒的节目。我从人们那里得到的反馈是他们很喜欢它。是的，我认识的每个人都看了，很喜欢，而且对此赞不绝口。是的，是的，他们甚至没喝醉，没嗑药，没清醒，都是聪明人。他们没有被枪指着头。没有。
I'm sorry to the listener. This is probably a couple months later, but I just want to say congrats, Willie. You guys, you and your whole team, they're put together a really great show. The feedback I'm getting from people just loved it. Yeah, everybody I know saw it, loved it, and it was like over the top about it. Yeah, yeah, they weren't even drunk, they weren't high, they weren't sober, smart people. They didn't have guns held to their head. No.
是的，我会征求意见。嗯，听着，我感谢你们俩当时的支持，我再次感到非常幸运，我能做到这一点。再一次，这在过去几天一直在我脑海中，我想，我发布了一些关于它的东西，不是不情愿的，但你必须把它作为你事情的一部分来做。你的费用。这就是他们付钱让你做的，他们给你发东西，他们说，发布这个，然后你就说，是的。
Yeah, I'll solicit it. Well, listen, I thank both of you guys at the time, and I'm so lucky again that I get to do it. Again, that's been kind of on my mind the last couple of days, I'm like, I posted something about it, not reluctantly, but you have to do it as part of your thing. Your fee. That's what they pay you to do, and they send you stuff, they're like, post this, and you're like, yeah.
我能看，我正在看花絮，我正在看我们能做这件事的 3F 傻瓜，这就像，这不是一份工作。我再次想到它，就像尤金一样，事实上，你知道，它不是，我绝不会把它和克里斯的选角放在同一个水平上，所以请收回你们的烂评论，但你知道，我们必须做这件事，我们必须胡闹。我们对剧本有一个松散的想法，而且有点奏效，然后我们可以在这个游戏中胡闹和玩乐。嗯，为什么你不继续保持下去，让我们保持这个剧团，为每一个……
And I get to look, and I'm looking at the outtake stuff, and I'm looking at the 3F idiots that we get to do this thing, and it's like, it's not a job. And I was thinking about it again, like with Eugene, and in fact, you know, it's not, I'm not putting it on the same level as Chris cast it by any means, so please hold back on your shit comments, but you know, we got to do this thing where we got to mess around. We had a loose idea of what the script was, and kind of worked, and then we got to kind of fuck around and have fun in this game. Well, why don't you keep that going, let's keep this troop going and do it for each sort
比如下一个应该是《谁杀了复活节兔子》，我们有时间在春天之前完成，然后我们，你知道。而我只是扮演所有被杀的角色。你扮演兔子，是的，然后你被杀了。复活节兔子会怎么死？如果圣诞老人死于尖锐的糖果手杖。复活节兔子会死于沙门氏菌。沙门氏菌，是的，或者被一个流氓蛋壳撕裂。
of, like the next should be who killed the Easter Bunny, we have that in time for spring, and then we, you know. And I just play all the characters who get killed. You get to be the bunny, yeah, and you get killed. How would the Easter Bunny die? If Santa died from a sharp candy cane. The Easter Bunny would die from salmonella. Salmonella, yeah, or more lacerated by a, by a rogue egg shell.
该死的，该死的沙门氏菌。拜托，它必须不同。我甚至不是有人向我指出，这是真的。兔子的篮子里装满了蛋。蛋，对吧。是的。那发生了什么？是的。
Fucking, fucking salmonella. Come on, it's got to be different. I'm not even somebody pointing out to me, it is true. The bunny's got a basket full of eggs. Eggs, right. Yeah. What happened with that? Yeah.
哦，也许这就是他死的原因。尤金·列维真是太搞笑了，我刚才想说，就像你怎么，像《福音》那件事的几率是多少，那一群人，然后那一群人去了第二城市，然后那一群人一起演了所有那些克里斯·盖斯特的电影。是的。这就像一个紧密的朋友圈，他们待在一起并制作东西。这就像梦想成真。
Oh, maybe that's how he died. That Eugene Levy is just so funny, and was I just going to say, like how do you, what are the odds of like the God spell thing, all that troupe of people, then that troupe of people goes on in Second City, then that troupe of people plays together in all those Chris Guest movies. Yeah. And it's just like this tight circle of friends that stay together and make stuff. That's like a dream come true.
而且没有，我是说，我相信从那以后有很多来自加拿大的极其搞笑、有才华的喜剧演员，但从来没有像那个时代那样涌现出来，对吧？我想知道那是什么。那是一个令人难以置信的天才高度集中的时期。嗯，我必须说这一点，我不仅仅是在说威尔，但你，迈克·迈尔斯，吉姆·凯瑞，尤金·列维，凯瑟琳·欧哈拉，就像所有这些来自那里的人。这很奇怪。
And there hasn't been, I mean, I'm sure that there have been plenty incredibly hilarious, talented comic actors coming out of Canada since then, but never in that same kind of flood that came out during that era, right? I wonder what that was. It was a very concentrated time of incredible talent. Well, I have to say this, and I'm not just saying this well, but you, Mike Myers, Jim Kerry, Eugene Levy, Catherine O'Hara, like all of these people that come from there. It's weird.
就像什么？所有那些人。就像他说的那样，除了那些离开并去了 SNL 的其他人，就像在那个时候，想想，顺便说一句，包括劳伦，他创造了 SNL。对，对。所以在 70 年代中期到后期，就像在 75 年和 76 年，顺便说一句，那是美国的。建国两百周年。
It's like what? All those people. And like he said, in addition to the other people who left and went to SNL, like in that time, think about, and by the way, including Lauren, who created SNL. Right, right. So in that mid to late 70s, like right in like 75 and then 76, which incidentally was the America's. By Centennial.
再见！哦，是的！你做到了！聪明。对。聪明。对。聪明。
Bye! Oh yeah! You did it! Smart. Right. Smart. Right. Smart.
对。对。对。对。对。聪明。对。SmartList 是 100% 有机的，由 Rob Armjarv、Bennett Barbocco 手工制作，
Right. Right. Right. Right. Right. Smart. Right. SmartList is 100% organic and are tisently handcrafted by Rob Armjarv, Bennett Barbocco,
和 Michael Grant。Terry。聪明。对。我们的下一集将在下周播出，无论你在哪里收听播客，或者你现在就可以在 Amazon Music 上提前收听，或者通过订阅 Apple Podcasts 或 Wondery App 中的 Wondery Plus 提前且无广告地收听。嘿，我是迈克·科里，Wondery 播客《逆境求生》的主持人。
and Michael Grant. Terry. Smart. Right. Our next episode will be out in a week, wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music, or early and add free by subscribing to Wondery Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondery App. Hey, I'm Mike Corey, the host of Wondery's podcast Against the Odds.
每周，我们都会分享惊心动魄的真实生存故事，让你身临其境地感受那些幸存下来的英雄们的故事。在我们的下一季中，我们将带你前往阿拉斯加的一个偏远角落，那里是世界上棕熊密度最高的地区之一。但近年来，气候变化导致熊的天然食物来源短缺。越来越多的熊冒险进入阿拉斯加海恩斯镇寻找食物，让居民们感到紧张。
Each week, we share thrilling true stories of survival and put you in the shoes of the heroes who live to tell the tale. In our next season, we take you to a remote corner of Alaska that's home to one of the densest brown bear populations in the world. But in recent years, the changing climate has caused a shortage of the bear's natural food sources. More and more bears are venturing into the town of Haines, Alaska, in search of food, putting residents on edge.
然后，每个人最担心的恐惧变成了现实。三名经验丰富的野外滑雪者在不知情的情况下滑过一个洞穴，惊醒了一只母熊和她的幼崽。她发动了攻击，其中一名男子在生死边缘挣扎，而他的朋友们则绝望地等待救援。在任何你获取播客的地方关注《逆境求生》。你可以在 Amazon Music 或 Wondery App 上无广告收听。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
Then, everyone's worst fears are realized. Three experienced backcountry skiers unknowingly ski over a den and awaken a mother bear and her cub. She attacks and one of the men is left fighting for his life while his friends desperately wait for help to arrive. Follow Against the Odds wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen ad-free on the Amazon Music or Wondery App. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
随后，每个人最担心的噩梦成真了。三名经验丰富的野外滑雪者在不知情的情况下滑过了一个兽穴，惊醒了一只母熊和它的幼崽。母熊发起了攻击，其中一名男子在生死边缘挣扎，而他的朋友们则在绝望中等待救援。请在各大播客平台关注《Against the Odds》。您可以在Amazon Music或Wondery App上收听无广告版本。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。